>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A COMEDIAN THAT USED TO WORK FOR
THE FOOD NETWORK, HE'S ALSO
PRO-LIFE.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, HE WAS
PREPARING TO HOST A COMEDY SHOW
IN RUTHERFORD, NEW JERSEY, A
HALF HOUR OUTSIDE OF NEW YORK,
BUT MINUTES AFTER THE SHOW WAS
ANNOUNCED ANTIFA, A VIOLENT
RADICAL GROUP, DECIDED TO SHUT
IT DOWN.
HUNDREDS OF ANTIFA AFFILIATED
TWITTER ACCOUNTS STARTED
BOMBARDING THE VENUE, CALLED THE
WILLIAMS CENTER.
THEY ALSO WENT AFTER THE CHIEF
OF POLICE AND THREATENED
VIOLENCE.
AT THAT POINT, THE CHIEF OF
POLICE WHO WANTED TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION, THE FREE SPEECH OF
EVERY AMERICAN, BUT HE CAVED TO
THE MOB.
HE WARNED THE VENUE THAT THE
VENUE MIGHT SAVE CIVIL LIABILITY
IF THEY ALLOWED FREE SPEECH TO
GO ON, THE SHOW TO GO ON.
THEN SAID HE WOULD SHUT DOWN THE
SHOW ON PUBLIC SAFETY GROUNDS.
ULTIMATELY THE WILLIAMS CENTER
HAD NO CHOICE AND CANCELED THE
SHOW.
IN THE END, THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED UP AT THE WILLIAMS CENTER
THAT NIGHT WERE SEVERAL POLICE
OFFICERS, THERE TO MAKE SURE
THERE WAS NO COMEDY TAKING
PLACE.
NONE AT ALL.
THEN TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY,
THE NEXT MORNING, THE MAYOR OF
RUTHERFORD, NEW JERSEY, BRAGGED
ABOUT WHAT THE CITY HAD DONE.
HE SAID IT WAS HIS DECISION TO
USE THE POWER OF THE STATE TO
CUT DOWN COMEDY.
QUOTE, UNBEKNOWNST TO THE
BOROUGH, HE WROTE, AN EVENT WAS
PLANNED THIS EVENING FOR THE
WILLIAMS CENTER, NEWS OF WHICH
QUICKLY CIRCULATED THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA.
ONLINE INTELLIGENCE LED THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT TO BELIEVE
THAT THE EVENT HAD THE POTENTIAL
FOR CONFRONTATION.
THEREFORE AFTER DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OWNER, THE EVENT HAS BEEN
CANCELED.
NOW NOTICE THE BLAME SHIFTING
HERE.
THE POTENTIAL FOR CONFRONTATION.
IT WASN'T THE COMEDIAN WHO WAS
GOING TO CONFRONT OR THREATEN
ANYONE WITH VIOLENCE.
IT WAS THE RADICAL LEFT WING
GROUP ANTIFA, BUT IT WAS THE
COMEDIAN WHO WAS PUNISHED.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME JOSH
DENEY HAS EXPERIENCED THIS.
IT'S HAPPENED FOUR TIMES IN JUST
THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
SHOWS CANCELED BECAUSE OF
THREATS FROM THE LEFT.
TWO SHOWS WERE CANCELED IN
CHICAGO.
ANOTHER TWO IN NEW YORK.
EVERY TIME THE SAME PATTERN.
DENEY WOULD SCHEDULE A COMEDY
SHOW, AND A HUGE AMOUNT OF
ANTIFA AFFILIATED TWITTER
ACCOUNTS COLLAPSED UNDER THE
PRESSURE AND SHUT IT DOWN.
DENNY CAN NO LONGER PEEK.
ONLY WAY TO HOST A SHOW NORTH OF
THE MASON-DIXON LINE IS DELIVER
CRYPTIC TWEETS TO HIS FRIENDS
WHERE TO MEET LIKE AT A
SUBMARINING EASY.
ALL ANTIFA HAS TO DO ITS SEND
TWEETS.
JOSH DENNY'S NOT THE ONLY
PERFORMER BEING TARGETED.
IT'S PART OF A LARGER CAMPAIGN
TO END FREE SPEECH IN THE UNITED
STATES, A COUNTRY WHOSE CIVIC
RELIGION WAS FREE SPEECH JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO.
THIS IS A HUGE CHANGE AND AN
OMINOUS ONE.
ANYONE WHO TELLS YOU YOU CAN'T
SAY WHAT YOU TRULY BELIEVE IS A
TOTALLARIAN.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SENSITIVITY.
IT'S ABOUT CONTROLLING YOU.
IT'S TOTALLARIAN.
WE'RE GOING TO START TONIGHT
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
COMEDIANS, BECAUSE FREE SOCIETY
REQUIRES COMEDIANS.
COMEDY IS THE WAY WE TELL THE
TRUTH.
THE PRESENCE OF COMEDIANS IN A
SOCIETY MEANS THAT YOU GET TO
MOCK THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE.
VERY QUICKLY, AND IT'S NOT AN
ACCIDENT, WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
COMEDIANS.
ONLY ROTE COMEDY IS TOLERATED
NOW.
THAT'S ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING NO
COMEDY IS TOLERATED NOW.
ELON MUSK POINTED THIS OUT A FEW
MONTHS AT THE SATIRE SITE, THE
BABYLON BEE.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
IS COMEDY GETTING AT AN
ESSENTIAL TRUTH OR TRYING TO --
OR IS THERE -- IS THERE A
PROPAGANDA ELEMENT OR A -- IS IT
TRYING TO PUSH YOU IN A
PARTICULAR DIRECTION OR -- OR --
OR GETTING TO AN ESSENTIAL TRUTH
THAT IS HUMOROUS.
WHEN IT STOPS GETTING TO AN
ESSENTIAL TRUTH THAT'S HUMOROUS
IT'S NOT --
>> Tucker: AFTER THAT INTERVIEW,
TWITTER, AS IF TO PROVE IT HAS
NO SENSE OF HUMOR AS WELL, THEY
BANNED THE BABYLON BEE, MAKING
FUN OF THAT GUY IN A DRESS
THEY'RE CALLING FEMALE.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
ELON MUSK BOUGHT TWITTER.
WHAT IS CLEAR AT THIS POINT
AFTER ELON MUSK FIRED HALF OF
TWITTER'S EMPLOYEES, TWITTER GOT
BETTER.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE CENSORS.
AND TWITTER ISN'T THE ONLY
COMPANY, MANY OF WHOSE EMPLOYEES
WORK EFFECTIVELY AS CENSORS TO
SHUT DOWN YOUR FREEDOM TO SAY
WHAT YOU THINK, OUTSIDE NETFLIX
HEADQUARTERS LAST YEAR,
PROTESTERS, SOME OF THEM NETFLIX
EMPLOYEES, GATHERED TO DEMAND
THE CENSOR OF DAVE CHAPPELLE.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT DO WE WANT?
>> TO GO IN THE BUILDING.
>> WHEN DO YOU WANT TO?
>> NOW.
>> IT'S OKAY TO LAUGH, BUT
YOU'RE SPARKING HATE
CONVERSATION.
>> BLACK LIVES MATTER!
>> WHY ARE YOU BREAKING MY SIGN?
YOU'RE BREAKING MY SIGN.
>> HE'S GOT A WEAPON.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT YOU HAD AT
NETFLIX IS ALSO WHAT YOU HAD AT
TWITTER.
IT'S THE SAME PHENOMENON THAT'S
CANCELING COMEDIANS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, A SMALL GROUP OF
POLITICALLY INFLAMED HIGHLY
MOTIVATED EXTREMISTS WHO PREVENT
THE MAJORITY FROM SAYING WHAT IT
THINKS.
ANOTHER WORD FOR THAT IS
TYRANNY.
IT'S EVERYWHERE.
ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE IN
HOLLYWOOD WILLING TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THIS, SAY WHAT HE REALLY
THINKS, IS ADAM CAROLLA, A
LONGTIME COMEDIAN WHO'S STAYED
TRUE AND THEREFORE FUNNY.
HE MOCKED THE PEOPLE YOU JUST
SAW AS EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE,
HUMORLESS BABIES.
>> I NEED TO EXPLAIN TO THE
PEOPLE AT NETFLIX, WHICH IS AN
INTERESTING -- ANOTHER
INTERESTING DYNAMIC IS, YOUR JOB
ISN'T THAT IMPORTANT, AND IT
DOESN'T REALLY CHANGE HEARTS AND
MINDS.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE THIS THING
WHERE IT'S, LIKE, DAVE CHAPPELLE
IS GOING TO MOBILIZE THIS GROUP
OF OUR SOCIETY, WHICH NEVER
REALLY SEEMS TO BE MOBILIZED.
LIKE HIS WORDS, HIS WORDS HURT,
AND HIS WORDS ARE GOING TO CAUSE
X, Y AND Z.
NO, THEY'RE NOT.
HE'S A COMEDIAN, GETS TO SAY
WHAT HE WANTS, HE GETS PAID, YOU
GET PAID, AND THAT'S CALLED
ENTERTAINMENT.
>> Tucker: HE'S A COMEDIAN.
HE GETS TO SAY WHAT HE WAN